Yeah, I got to go back and grab something from the pilot because I realized after we finished taping that one of my favorite lines and moments in the pilot that Ted got to say, I forgot to mention and it's when he's talking to Yasmeen and he says, it's not like a sit-around all day fantasizing about my wedding and then he goes into this whole very specific fantasy about his wedding, which he ends with, bam, no DJ, people will dance, I'm not going to worry about it, right?
And I loved the phrase people will dance.
Like as a notion of like, I'm not going to worry about it.
It became shorthand in my life.
The woman that I was seeing when I got how I met your mother who worked on the audition sides with me.
She was Eastern European and she found that also so charming.
And our mantra was, and she would say it in this accent that was adorable to me.
People would dance.
I'm not going to worry about it.
Like it'll take care of itself.
And I named my corporation people will dance.
Like it really became this mantra of, remember what I said?
All people want to be told is it's going to be okay.
Yes.
For me, the phrase people will dance is that it's still that in my head.
Like people will dance.
Like people are going to have a good time.
You don't have to micromanage every last bit of life or this evening or whatever.
So that, to me, I suppose if I was getting a phrase from how I met her with her tattooed, I don't have any tattoos, but people from the world all over the world get to, how I met your mother tattoos.
I've seen a lot of how I met your mother tattoos.
If I were getting one, it would probably be people will dance.
Hey, welcome to a very special bonus episode of how we made your mother.
This is an episode we call General Questions.
General Questions.
I'm Josh Radder.
I am here with, who am I here with?
You hear what's Craig Thomas?
Craig Thomas, the co-creator of how I met your mother and our friend, Alec Lev, and we're going to burn through some reader mail, harkening back to Carter and Craig's origins of doing the letterman reader mail.
We should back it up for a second.
I'll read and say that the running joke on how much weather doesn't start till season two, but whenever anybody says, I have a general question or I have a major problem, everyone And so it's in such a general question, major problem, that's general questions.
Yeah, that is the, and this is my, my proudest, my proudest moment in life was when I turned on the TV one Monday night, and there was this stupid, saluting thing that I know it everyone with in college, but they all picked it up, Craig, so we work and I went to college to go to a living on in college.
He brainwashed me into doing this.
There is something sticky social contagion about the joke.
For some reason, even if you've grown the first time you hear it, once you get it in your head, so it's major general and what else?
Oh, private.
You can have a private conversation.
Private conversation.
Yeah.
You can, but you could take it.
You could take it very far.
We'll get into that as we don't want to give it all the way right here, but yes, there's a season two bit on the show.
Alec, did I ask you permission to steal this bill?
There was this one of the many, many times.
I just stole things like I'm like a fucking dick.
No, but this this was truly the proudest and I will say that was it a surprise to be honest was it a surprise?
I'm thinking it was just that I never really was I guess I probably chose to surprise you because I knew you would like it I will say that I have a very good friend who told me that she used to do this with her friend You know 10 years ago 15 years ago from the show dude all the time I was like that's all coming in a circle But speaking of bringing a circle and I'm just happy you're finally gonna get credit for this, Alex.
This is something.
This has been a long time coming.
All like, this is why I'm doing this podcast, my friends.
But to show how long a tale and amazing a story this is, Josh, you got an incredible letter.
I got, I got an unbelievable note.
I won't say their names unless they, they authorize it because they didn't really write this for us to share the podcast, but it's so incredible.
We have to share it.
And fitting with me, stealing it from Alex, we're just going to steal this kind of viewers.
This is from a couple who said, this is the husband writing me, that his wife was 38 weeks pregnant with their daughter.
And the wife had had several days of early labor and pain before they finally admitted her to the hospital.
And then she had over 30 hours of labor in the hospital, which you guys have had wives who've given birth.
That's a long time, right?
That's a long run, man.
That's 30 hours of labor with her last pushes.
The nurse said, push, you're having a major contraction and through all the pain and pushing, my wife looks at me and salutes to major contraction.
It's just the best.
It's just the best story.
It's an unbelievable story.
That's so good.
It's so good.
So, we thank you to the mighty marvelous couple out there who did a how I met your mother inside joke at the moment of pushing a baby out.
And it's our joke is the baby came out, I mean, what a major contraction, I mean, major respect to this amazing woman and to whatever lucky gentleman got to marry her and have a child with her.
That's unbelievable.
That's how you know this.
Did you ever know?
That's how you know this marriage is going to last.
I mean, it's really, I have no doubt about that marriage and Alec could, did high school you that began this joke that presumably everyone hated you for?
Sure.
of imagined this, this would boomerang back around to us.
And like that, this could possibly is this a, this a blow your mind.
No, that was the point.
That was the point.
The whole time.
You played a long game.
The world.
And this is the long, the long, the long.
And it was college.
I held off until I met you.
I didn't annoy them in high school.
Yeah.
I thought it was cool to bust it out freshman here in college.
All right.
So, you know, we're, we've We only announced a show, a little time-ending here.
We announced the show in our lives, not that long ago, and have been flooded not only with stories, but also literally a minute before we recorded our episode about the pilot.
I went on to Instagram and I said, hey, does anyone have any questions?
And by the time the hour was done of recording, I had 350 of them, and I got to precisely almost zero because Josh and Craig just had so much to say about the pilot.
So we thought we'd hold it off and just do a rapid fire, get some of the fan questions out here.
Some of these you will have answered before.
And a lot of these are one question represents 10 questions that were of the same topic.
So let's just dive in.
So Alice, 2388 asks, Josh, how much do you relate to Ted in real life?
I'll say that's a big question.
That's what we're going to be talking about through the whole series.
So I'm going to bend it a little bit if that's okay.
所以如果可以的话，我要稍微转换一下话题。
In our last episode, you said you sort of gave grace to your younger Josh Self.
在上一集里，你说你对年轻时的乔什·塞尔夫网开一面。
You had some advice for your younger Josh Self who was feeling certain things.
你对当时有着某些感受的年轻乔什·塞尔夫给了一些建议。
What would older Ted have to say to younger Ted in the pilot?
那么，年长的特德会对试播集里的年轻特德说些什么呢？
He's a, he was a very intense guy.
他是一个，他以前是个非常情绪激烈的人。
Yeah.
对。
What, what can you give him?
你、你能给他什么？
Well, I, I mean, it's more like, I mean, acting is so strange.
嗯，我，我的意思是，更像是，我的意思是，表演太奇怪了。
I, I always, um, think about what my acting teacher did and why you said Ron Bandleau.
我，我总是，嗯，会想起我的表演老师做过的事，以及你为什么提到罗恩·班德洛。
he said, a character is a 50% meeting of you and the character.
他说，一个角色是你和角色50%的结合。
So I lend 50% of the kind of DNA and the character, as Crack and Carter wrote, wrote the character is also that other 50%.
所以我贡献了50%的基因，而正如克雷克和卡特所写的，角色也是另外的50%。
So you're kind of like meeting this other thing to form this thing that looks like a dimensional real person.
所以你有点像是与另一个事物相遇，从而塑造出一个看起来像是一个立体的、真实的人。
So I'm loathed to kind of act like 10.
所以我很讨厌表现得像10号。
I don't know when people say like, oh, do it like 10.
我不知道当人们说，哦，就像10号那样演。
I'm like, I don't know.
我就想，我不知道。
looked at us to do things in character.
看着我们按角色行事。
I'm like, I don't know what you mean, like without the words from the script, like there is nothing, there's no character, but I am underneath the skin of him where I was for a long time.
我就想，我不知道你是什么意思，如果没有剧本里的台词，那就什么都没有，没有角色，但我曾长时间身处于他的皮囊之下。
I think, you know, if my younger self had told a woman that he was wildly attracted to that he loved her on the first date and kind of blew it.
我想，你知道吧，如果我年轻时对一个他疯狂爱慕的女人在第一次约会时就表白说爱她，结果把事情搞砸了。
And I knew what I know now, I would say, you know, Humiliation is part of life like it's a it's a it's almost like initiatory like you get humiliated and I was listening to this guy Scott Galoway who's a really interesting thinker and he's he's talking about men the kind of crisis of Manhood and he said when men are just on their screens alone.
如果我知道现在所知道的，我会说，你知道的，羞辱是生活的一部分，它就像是一种，它几乎就像是一种洗礼，你会受到羞辱，我当时在听一个叫斯科特·加洛韦的家伙的节目，他是一个非常有趣的思想家，他在谈论男性，关于男子气概的危机，他说当男人只独自面对屏幕时。
They don't know how to take big swings out in the world They they need to go out and and learn to be humiliated now.
他们不知道如何在现实世界中大胆一试，他们需要走出去，学会去承受羞辱。
I learned to be humiliated honestly somewhat by women, but not as much.
说实话，我学会面对羞辱在某种程度上是通过女性，但没有那么多。
Here's what taught me humiliation was being a young actor.
真正教会我羞辱的是做年轻演员的经历。
Going in, roll after roll, sometimes nailing it, not getting the job, sometimes getting the job, sometimes blowing it, you know, being unprepared or just getting too nervous.
一次又一次地去试镜，有时表现出色却没得到工作，有时得到了工作，有时又搞砸了，你知道的，准备不足或者只是太紧张了。
Like, I really had to learn how to be humiliated and pick myself back up and keep going.
真的，我必须学会如何面对羞辱，然后重新振作起来，继续前行。
And I think it's one of the great qualities of Ted, which I hope I share, Is this ability to get knocked down?
我认为这是特德最伟大的品质之一，我也希望自己能拥有，那就是被击倒后的韧性。
And he sometimes literally, like he got punched a lot in the show, like he sometimes literally gets punched down, and he gets back up.
有时甚至是字面意义上的，比如他在剧中经常挨揍，有时真的被打倒在地，但他还是会站起来。
So I think it's more like, if someone's, you know, if a younger person says, I got humiliated as an older mentor figure, I think you say, good, yeah, this is what you need, you need to be humiliated.
所以我觉得更像是，如果有人，你知道的，如果一个年轻人说，我受到了羞辱，作为一个年长的导师形象，我想你会说，很好，是的，这正是你需要的，你需要经历羞辱。
You need to take swings, you need to put yourself out there and you need to get somewhat, You get need to get a thicker skin, you get need to get immune to the kind of criticism and humiliation and just keep going.
你需要大胆尝试，你需要把自己置于公众视野中，你还需要多少经历一些，你需要脸皮变厚，你需要对各种批评和羞辱产生免疫力，然后继续前行。
So I would just tell them to pick himself up and it's all going to be all right.
所以我只想告诉他要重新振作起来，一切都会好起来的。
Ultimately, I think all anyone wants to hear is it's going to be okay.
归根结底，我想任何人只想听到一句“一切都会好起来的”。
Yes.
是的。
Like that's all anyone wants to hear ever.
就像那是所有人永远都想听到的话。
Yeah.
对。
It's the most evergreen piece of like pep talk advice you could give.
这是你能给出的最永不过时的鼓励话语。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我为你写了这首小曲，要在纽约市唱给你听。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the HyperFixed podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼，《HyperFixed》播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这些问题：我30岁了，在纽约开车感到很害怕。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我倒车时不能调节车载音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也会解决与汽车无关的问题。
You have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that caused that problem in the first place.
只要你有问题，我们不仅会解决它，还会揭示导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed podcast from Radio Topia.
这就是来自 Radio Topia 的《HyperFixed》播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
你可以在各大播客平台或访问 HyperFixedPod.com 收听。
Craig, the Dodger Munch asks a question you must have gotten a lot back in the day, but let's cover it officially now.
克雷格，“道奇·芒奇”问了一个你以前肯定经常被问到的问题，但我们现在正式探讨一下。
Why did you cast Bob Sagitt as the old Ted, which we could split that into two questions.
为什么你选鲍勃·萨吉特来演年老的特德，我们可以把这个问题拆成两个。
Why was there an old Ted period and why Bob Sagitt?
为什么会有年老的特德这个设定，以及为什么是鲍勃·萨吉特？
Yeah, great.
对，太棒了。
The great Bob Saga.
伟大的鲍勃·萨吉。
By the way, let's yeah, the great Bob Saga.
顺便说一句，让我们，对，伟大的鲍勃·萨吉。
And we will, we will get to the episode where we do a whole episode is about how much we love Bob Saga and how much we miss Bob Saga and how lucky we were to work with him.
我们会，我们会聊到那一集，那一整集都是关于我们有多爱鲍勃·萨吉，我们有多怀念鲍勃·萨吉，以及与他合作是多么幸运。
I'm so glad that we did it.
我很高兴我们当时那样做了。
I will say that when we were first writing it, we thought the actor who played Ted would do the voiceover.
我得说，刚开始写剧本的时候，我们以为饰演泰德的演员会来做画外音。
And in fact, I don't believe it was our idea to have an older person.
事实上，让一个年长的人来演，我觉得最初并不是我们的主意。
do the role.
来扮演这个角色。
I think CBS, an older scheming network at the time, we were the youngest show on that network for all nine years that we were on that network, I believe, I think that's true.
我觉得CBS当时是一个挺有心计的老牌电视网，在我们播出的整整九年里，我们一直是那个电视网里最年轻的节目，我想是的，我觉得确实如此。
I think the executives there said, because I think we talked, we had the idea, we considered a different actor doing that voice, but I think we were leaning more towards Josh would do it.
我觉得那里的高管说——因为我们当时讨论过，也有过这个想法，考虑过让另一个演员来配音，但我觉得我们更倾向于让乔什来做。
And I think I have to give credit to CBS and the studio for saying like, there will be something here on CBS to having a trusted voice of an actor in his 50s, who we've all grown up with, America's funny, some videos, full house, he feels like your dad, he feels like this trusted part, he's been in your living room before and it will help the viewers that are watching CBS feel connected to the show in a way that maybe they wouldn't.
而且我觉得我必须把功劳归于CBS和制片厂，他们说，在CBS启用一个50多岁、我们所有人都伴随着他的声音长大的演员的信任感，这在这里会很有意义——美国的《搞笑视频》、《欢乐满屋》，他感觉就像你的父亲，感觉像是这种值得信赖的一部分，他以前就进入过你的客厅，这会帮助正在收看CBS的观众以一种他们可能意想不到的方式与节目产生连接。
But that was sort of the practical part, the creative part, and I think this was more important, was this idea that future U is kind of a different guy, right?
但那算是比较实际的层面，而创意层面——我觉得这个更重要——就是这种理念，即未来的“你”其实是一个不同的人，对吧？
The guy, the Ted in 2005 and the Ted in 2030, they're different people, just like Josh and I are different people from 2005 and now, and having Bob do that role, he brought this kind of wisdom and warmth and to go back to Josh's question, ability to look back on having been humiliated with wit, humor, acceptance, grace, like he had that in his voice, he was a stand-up comedian Bob Sagit.
那个2005年的泰德和2030年的泰德，他们是不同的人，就像我和乔什是2005年和现在不同的人一样，让鲍勃来演这个角色，他带来了一种智慧、温暖，而且回到乔什的问题，他有一种能力，能用机智、幽默、包容和大度去回首自己曾经受过的羞辱，他的声音里就有这种特质，鲍勃·萨吉特本身就是个单口喜剧演员。
He went up and bombed in front of audiences.
他曾在观众面前搞砸过。
He killed in front of audiences.
他也曾在观众面前大获成功。
You hear all his history in his voice.
你能在他的声音里听到他所有的经历。
He's a fantastic actor too.
他也是个出色的演员。
He took the role really seriously.
他非常严肃地对待这个角色。
He really loved Josh.
他真的很喜欢乔什。
He tried to get to know Josh and connect with Josh.
他试图去了解乔什并与乔什建立联系。
So he was future Ted.
所以他就是年老的泰德。
He would come hang out on the set.
他会来到片场闲逛。
He didn't have to do that when he'd come to voiceovers.
他来录画外音时本来不用这么做的。
He'd come say hi because he wanted to feel what the show was and that sort of connection between these two Ted's but who were the same guy, but we're different guys, the way we all are.
他会来打个招呼，因为他想感受一下这部剧的氛围，以及这两个泰德之间的那种联系——他们虽然是同一个人，但又是不同的人，就像我们所有人一样。
And 30, 25 years apart, I think it became such an asset to the show.
而且相隔30年、25年，我觉得这成了这部剧的一大优势。
And I can't claim credit for it.
我可不能把这功劳揽在自己身上。
In fact, we may have had to be, I think we got convinced of it through the process.
事实上，我们可能不得不承认，我觉得我们是在这个过程中被说服的。
And we were willing to be resistant.
而且我们一开始其实是有点抗拒的。
You know, I had a couple moments where I was like, man, I wish I was doing the voice, but I love, I ended up loving Bob so much that I was so happy that there was this introduction and that we got to be friends all these years.
你知道的，我有好几次都在想：“天哪，我真希望是我自己在配音。”但后来我太喜欢鲍勃了，以至于我无比庆幸能有这样的引子，而且我们这些年能成为朋友。
But also it was fun to watch Bob.
不过看鲍勃录音也很有意思。
He became a fan of the show huge because he would watch it in the sound booth and he loved the show.
他成了这档节目超级狂热的粉丝，因为他会在录音室里看样片，他是真的很喜欢这部剧。
He was really he loved it.
他是真心很喜欢。
And yeah, I ultimately I ultimately think it was it was the right move and I'm so I'm so glad that I that I knew him.
是的，我最终觉得这是个正确的决定，我真的很高兴我认识了他。
And also, you know, he and I had some real deep talks about being overly associated with a show, because he had that with full house.
而且，你知道的，我和他也曾有过非常深入的交谈，关于如何避免被某部剧过度定型，因为他当年拍《欢乐满屋》时就经历过这些。
Yeah.
对。
So he offered me some real wisdom and more than anything, just the wisdom to keep going.
所以他给了我一些真正的智慧，更重要的是，给了我坚持下去的动力。
No, but I mean, thinking about Bob, Bob was a genius at complicating and diversifying his image past full house.
不，我是说，想想鲍勃，鲍勃在摆脱《欢乐满屋》的形象、让自己的戏路变得复杂和多样化方面简直是个天才。
He really appreciated it.
他真的很感激这一点。
Like, I'm going to show you some other moves.
就像是在说：“我要给你们露一手别的本事。”
I'm going to show you some other, which I was more really comfortable on my own skin.
“我要展现我其他的一面。”这让我对自己更加自信了。
I wish I was more comfortable working blue.
我真希望自己当时在开黄腔时能更自然一些。
That's not my thing.
那可不是我的风格。
But it only worked with him because you knew he was a wrench.
但这种风格只有在他身上才行得通，因为你知道他本质上是个硬汉。
You knew he was all heart underneath it.
你知道他内心深处充满了温情。
It came across and there was a perpetual wink in it.
那种特质流露出来，并且总带着一种心照不宣的调侃。
Yeah, absolutely.
对，绝对是的。
That's how it was fun.
所以才那么有趣。
No, no, no, no.
不，不，不，不。
Zero, no, zero, no, zero, no.
零，没有，零，没有，零，没有。
I love.
我喜欢。
Yeah.
对。
Dr. Marie 15 again has a big question.
玛丽15号医生又提出了一个大问题。
But Josh, can you think of a time in that during the pilot.
不过，乔什，你能想起拍试播集时的某个时刻吗？
In those early days, weeks when you felt like, oh, this group is clicking this cast.
在那些早期的时候，有些星期你会觉得，哦，这个团队，这个演员阵容太默契了。
Well, you know, Neil and I had done a play together, like a really intense John Robin Bates play like months before.
嗯，你知道的，尼尔和我之前一起演过一部话剧，几个月前演过一部非常紧张的约翰·罗宾·贝茨的剧。
So I knew we worked well together.
所以我知道我们合作得很愉快。
I mean, I think it was pretty immediate.
我的意思是，我觉得这种默契几乎是立竿见影的。
I knew from the testing audition situation that Kobe and I, you know, had a real fizz together.
从试镜的情况来看，我就知道科比和我之间有一种真正的化学反应。
And then when we got the whole gang together, I remember, I remember writers telling me that they all recognized that when the five of us were around that table was when the show felt so alive to them.
然后当我们将所有人聚齐时，我记得，我记得编剧告诉我，他们都意识到，当我们五个人围坐在桌旁时，才是这部剧让他们觉得最具生机的时候。
So they were, in Craig, you can back me up on this but like trying to write more for the five, you know, the five, the gang of five, I think it was, I remember the champagne night and maybe it was just because I was a little buzzed, but I definitely felt like we He made something really great and I have a quiet, good feeling about this because I had had everything happen to me in the world of making television pilots except getting a hit show.
所以他们——克雷格，你可以为我作证——当时正试图为这五个人写更多的戏，你知道的，五人组。我想起那是香槟之夜，也许只是因为我有点微醺，但我绝对觉得我们创造了一些非常棒的东西，而且我对这部剧有一种安静的、良好的感觉，因为我在电视试播集制作领域经历过世面上的一切，除了获得一部热门剧集。
I got fired from my first one, the second one got canceled after six episodes.
我的第一部剧被开除了，第二部在播出六集后被取消了。
The third one just didn't get picked up by the network, but I thought if anyone's going to go, I think it's going to be this one.
第三部甚至没有被电视网选中，但我想如果有什么剧能火的话，我觉得会是这部。
I had that real strong feeling.
我当时有那种非常强烈的感觉。
We have a question here from our co-producer, Doug's wife, Tally.
我们这里有一个问题来自我们的联合制片人、道格的妻子塔利。
great friend of the show.
节目的好朋友。
Tally does work blue.
塔利确实喜欢开荤笑话。
Tally said, what the fuck did they shoot all the future Ted scenes with the kids before they shot the rest of the show?
塔利说：“他们他妈的为什么要在拍剧集其余部分之前，先把所有未来泰德和孩子们的场景都拍完？”
Greg?
克雷格？
Well, we didn't shoot it all before, but we definitely got ahead of it.
嗯，我们并没有把它们全在前面拍完，但我们确实走在了前面。
And season two is when we kind of grabbed all the future-looking stuff that pertained to the very ending.
第二季的时候，我们把所有与最终结局相关的未来镜头都抓紧拍了。
And We grabbed other stuff that we thought could slide in here or there like thing just reactions and we tried to it was kind of funny we just tried to imagine some reactions and we had some ideas that we thought would apply to future future episode ideas but mostly we shot that ending piece with them right because they were going to if the show was in one years it was there were going to be too old and that's what happened and so we just grabbed it was it looking back of his real like Babe Ruth call your shot ball or move to be like clear the set.
我们还抓取了其他我们认为可以在这里或那里穿插进去的内容，比如一些反应镜头。我们试图去想象一些反应，这其实挺搞笑的，我们有一些想法认为它们适用于未来某集的构想，但主要是我们把那个结局部分和他们一起拍了，对吧？因为如果剧集播了很多年，他们就会长得太大了，事实也确实如此。所以我们把它拍下来，回过头来看，这真的有点像贝比·鲁斯指着方向击球，或者是那种清场的举动。
We need these two child actors, and they're going to sign non-disclosure forms, which they did.
我们需要这两个童星，他们要签署保密协议，他们确实也签了。
And we had one cameraman, we had one sound person, who also signed those forms, and everybody else in the set, that's usually a pretty crowded place.
我们只有一个摄像师，一个录音师，他们也签署了这些协议，而片场平时是一个相当拥挤的地方，其他所有人都被请出去了。
We cleared them out.
我们把他们清场了。
I think we did it at the beginning of a day or an end of a day, and we just, nobody else, me and Carter, Pam, Susie, those two actors, David and Lindsay, the kids.
我想我们是在一天开始或一天结束的时候做的，只有我们，没有别人，我和卡特、帕姆、苏茜，以及那两个演员，大卫和林赛，也就是孩子们。
And that was it.
就是这样。
And so we just thought we have to do this and if we, you know, however many years pass, we'll always have shot this.
所以我们当时想，我们必须这么做，无论过去多少年，我们至少把这个镜头拍下来了。
We'll never regret having grabbed it.
我们绝不会后悔拍下了这个镜头。
There's no way to grab it eight, nine years from now.
八、九年之后根本就拿不到了。
So we're going to get it now.
所以我们现在就要把它弄到手。
So we just, yeah, it was, it was an example of using the format of the show to really think forward and think about the future.
所以我们，是的，这是一个利用节目的形式来真正放眼未来、思考未来的例子。
The show is about the future.
这个节目讲的就是未来。
And so I think our brains were just in that mode.
所以我想我们的脑子当时就处于那种状态。
And so we said, let's do it.
于是我们就说，干吧。
Let's Let's grab it.
我们去把它拿下来。
We had the idea.
我们有了这个主意。
Let's grab it.
把它拿下。
We have a lot of questions about the order in which scenes were shot.
我们有很多关于场景拍摄顺序的问题。
And I feel like at another time, what might be good to go through just for for fans who don't really know the way TV is put together is kind of let's talk about how the show is happens from Monday through Friday.
我觉得在另一个时间，对于那些不太了解电视剧制作方式的粉丝来说，好好的过一遍这些内容会很不错，也就是我们来聊聊这个节目从周一到周五是怎么运作的。
So I feel like let's put a pin in that so people see the that Josh, do you remember after champagne moment after the show is edited?
所以我觉得我们先把这个记下来，让大家看到——乔希，你还记得香槟时刻之后，节目剪辑完的情形吗？
Do you remember just watching the pilot for the first time and what your reaction was Craig same question do you afterwards yeah I can't remember the the first time I saw it I can't remember if I got a link I think that Pam maybe invited us as a cast to watch it do you remember Craig do you remember showing I was gonna say I don't know if you got a link you might have got a fucking VHS tape oh yeah I don't know I don't remember but I remember yeah and then I ended up watching it a bunch of times with with an audience because we you know watched it with the the audience to get the laughter.
你还记得第一次看试播集时的反应吗？克雷格，同样的问题，看完之后呢？是的，我不记得我第一次看了，我不记得我是不是收到过链接，我想帕姆可能邀请过我们作为演员去观看，你还记得吗，克雷格，你记得放映吗？我本想说，我不知道你有没有收到链接，你可能收到了一盘该死的录像带，哦，是的，我不知道，我不记得了，但我记得，是的，然后我最终和观众一起看了好多次，因为我们知道，为了收听笑声，我们和观众一起看了。
I think, you know, I saw it a bunch.
我想，你知道的，我看了很多次。
I've seen the pilot probably more than any other episode.
我看的试播集可能比其他任何一集都多。
Yeah.
是的。
And Greg, you obviously saw it all through the editing process.
格雷格，你显然在整个剪辑过程中都看过了。
It's different for me because we edited the hell out of it.
对我的感觉不一样，因为我们对它进行了地狱般的剪辑。
You know, it wasn't like eight minutes up.
你知道的，它可不是说八分钟就完事了。
You know, it was like, it was supposed to be 22 minutes.
你知道的，它本应该是22分钟。
It was 31 or whatever it was.
结果是31分钟还是别的什么。
And we had to, we spent weeks whittling it and editing down.
我们不得不花了好几个星期去精简和剪辑。
At the weirdest part was watching a focus group test audience watch it with their dials of like, like, and don't like.
最诡异的部分是看着焦点小组测试观众观看它，他们手里拿着那种表示喜欢和不喜欢的表决旋钮。
And these dials that are all averaged together of this room for the people watching it in real time, you see the lines going up and down of male approval or disapproval and female approval or disapproval.
这些旋钮的数据在这个房间里实时平均显示出来，你可以看到代表男性认可或不认可、女性认可或不认可的线条上下波动。
I think one's blue and one's pink in a stereotypical fashion.
我想一个是蓝色，一个是粉色，挺有刻板印象风格的。
And it's like, ooh, women like that moment, men did not.
就像是，哦，女性喜欢那个时刻，男性不喜欢。
And people, it's just so weird.
而且大家，这真的太奇怪了。
So I watched the pilot every way you could possibly watch the pilot and it was super weird, some of them.
所以我通过所有可能的方式看了一遍试播集，而且有些方式超级奇怪。
But then when we had it locked or almost locked and showed it to a live audience and recorded their laughs and their responses, which was what aired in the show.
但后来当我们把剪辑敲定或接近敲定，并把它放给现场观众看、记录他们的笑声和反应时——这就是节目中播出的内容。
For that one, that was fantastic because people, you knew it worked.
对于那一次，这太棒了，因为你知道，观众的反应说明它成功了。
You knew it worked.
你知道它成功了。
I knew it worked before that because everybody that came into the edit room and watched it, every moment that had to work worked.
在那之前我就知道它成功了，因为所有走进剪辑室观看的人，每一个必须起效的时刻都起效了。
So I felt confident, but the best moment was finally getting to show a two-in- audience full of humans and not assessing it in any way they were watching it and reacting naturally.
所以我感到很有信心，但最好的时刻终于还是向满满一屋子真实人类的观众展示，他们没有任何先入为主地观看，并做出自然的反应。
How much Craig at the time, and this might have changed over the course, the show became more successful and you more confident in this new crazy job that you had.
克雷格当时受到的影响有多大——随着节目变得更成功，你对这份疯狂的新工作更有自信，这种情况可能会有所改变。
How much of these other voices, whether it's audience reaction or test audience reaction or executives, how much is actually influencing your writing of the show?
这些其他声音，无论是观众的反应、试播观众的反应还是高管的意见，实际上在多大程度上影响了你对节目的编写？
Yeah, I mean, I think a good note is a good note.
是的，我的意思是，我认为好的意见就是好意见。
I think we had some very smart executives from both the studio and the network who were really believed in the show and supported it.
我认为我们有一些来自制片厂和电视网的非常聪明的行政人员，他们真的很相信这个节目并支持它。
it.
它。
And it took some time, sometimes for people for them to get on board, but sort of have serialized the show was and sort of emotional and stuff like that.
而且这需要一些时间，有时需要人们去适应，比如这个节目是几集连贯的序列剧，还有那种情感等等。
But for the most part, they just want to spend for the show.
但大多数情况下，他们只是想为节目出力。
And it was actually very helpful because we didn't shoot it in front of a live studio audience.
这其实非常有用，因为我们并不是在现场观众面前拍摄的。
So those responses meant something.
所以那些反应是有意义的。
If we got notes about confusion or boredom or something was slow and just it came from that human like, And executive is saying to me, I felt confused here, or this felt really rushed to me.
如果我们收到关于困惑、无聊或者觉得节奏慢的意见，那正是来自于那种人类的直觉，比如高管对我说：“我在这里感到困惑”，或者“我觉得这部分节奏太急促了”。
That's good.
这很好。
That's really useful.
这真的很有用。
That's a human reaction.
这是一种人类的反应。
They felt that in their gut and they told us.
他们内心感受到了这一点，并告诉了我们。
The other thing that was really useful, and I think Carter pointed this out in his episode, the crew reacted when we'd perform these scenes, the actors would perform these scenes.
另一件非常有用的事，我想卡特在他的那一集里也提到过，就是当演员们表演这些场景时，剧组工作人员的反应。
And the crew wouldn't have read every line of every script or like the new rewrite or whatever that came out the night before we shot.
剧组并没有读过每一份剧本的每一行台词，也没有读过我们在拍摄前一晚写出的新重写台词之类的东西。
And they'd react honestly to stuff.
他们会对内容做出真实的反应。
They'd really laugh.
他们真的会笑。
That's the only way.
这是唯一的途径。
And go cricket silence.
或者一片死寂。
And then it was only that first time.
而且那只代表第一次的反应。
So you had to aggregate responses.
所以你必须综合各种反应。
You're getting some responses from different places.
你从不同的地方获得一些反馈。
And you aggregate them.
然后你把它们综合起来。
And especially if you see link ups, and you're like, oh, that didn't work in three different settings now.
特别是如果你发现某些问题有关联，就会想，哦，这在三个不同的场合下都没起作用。
It didn't work at the table read, the crew didn't laugh, et cetera, et cetera.
它在围读时没起作用，剧组人员没笑，诸如此类。
And you sort of had to take the hit and go, okay, let's take this as a sign.
你基本上得接受这个打击，然后想，好吧，把这当作一个信号。
We may need to change it.
我们可能需要改变它。
Some stuff you got to believe in, even if it doesn't play on its feet in front of the crew, you say, this is a quiet moment we can, well, this will work in the other room.
有些东西你必须坚信，即使它在剧组面前现场演出来没有效果，你也会说，这是一个安静的时刻，我们可以，嗯，这在另一个场景里会起作用。
There's a different kind of moment.
那是另一种时刻。
So it's a case by case.
所以这得具体情况具体分析。
And Josh, I assume you're basically at this point insulated from the larger, louder voices about the show should be more of this, the stuff that Craig and Carter are hearing.
乔伊，我想在这一点上，你基本上已经隔绝了那些关于“节目应该更偏向哪种风格”的更大、更吵闹的声音，也就是克雷格和卡特所听到的那些。
you in your process early on, can you talk a little bit about what is affecting you?
在你的早期创作过程中，你能聊聊是什么在影响你吗？
Because unlike a play where you're working on this one character and you know it's got to be contained within this two hours, you do have it in somewhere in your head of like the choices that I'm making for this character could live for years, could live as it turns out for a decade.
因为不像戏剧，你只需要琢磨这一个角色，并且知道它必须包含在这两个小时内，但在你的脑海里某处，你会意识到你为这个角色做出的选择可能会持续多年，事实证明甚至可以持续十年。
What's happening as you're developing that early on, obviously with the scripts that you're being handed?
在你早期发展这个角色的过程中，显然要结合你拿到的剧本，究竟发生了什么？
Yeah, I mean, I think any sort of notes from the Studio Network, I was super insulated from that on the pilot at the very least.
是的，我的意思是，我认为来自制片厂和电视网的任何意见，至少在试播集时，我都完全被隔绝在外了。
Then you end up getting to know the Studio Network executives, and they're there every week, and you become really friendly with them.
然后你最终会开始了解制片厂和电视网的高管，他们每周都在那儿，你和他们变得非常熟悉。
They never felt like the enemy was walking on to stage, you know.
你绝不会觉得敌人走进了片场，你知道的。
But I was very interested in process and in writing.
但我对创作过程和编剧工作非常感兴趣。
So I remember, I was probably alone, well, among the cast members, and Craig can tell me if I'm wrong, I was probably the most curious about process.
所以我记得，在演员当中我可能算是个例外——克雷格可以告诉我我有没有记错——我对创作过程大概是最好奇的。
I was probably the one who asked the most about what was coming up and what you guys were working on and what you were struggling with.
我可能也是那个问得最多的人，比如接下来要发生什么，你们在创作什么，你们遇到了什么困难。
And like, I was just, I had an endless appetite for those kinds of questions.
而且我就是，我对这类问题有着无尽的渴望。
Some of it was like a little bit like, what's coming down the pike?
其中有些感觉就像是，接下来会有什么发展？
Like I wanted to, you know, you become a fan of the show too.
就像我想，你知道的，你也成了这个节目的粉丝。
I was like, I want to know what happens to this guy that I'm playing.
我就想，我想知道我演的这个家伙最后怎么样了。
But you know, I still was a relative newcomer to the world of filmed entertainment.
但你知道，我对电影电视这个世界来说，相对还是个新人。
I had done it so much theater since I was 15 and theater, the mercy of theater and somewhat of the sadness of theater is it's a femoral.
我从15岁起演了那么多话剧，而话剧的残酷之处——某种程度上也是话剧的悲哀——在于它是短暂的。
It goes away.
它转瞬即逝。
You do it and then you have to keep doing it.
你演完了，然后你得继续演下一场。
It's much more like a restaurant where you have to keep making the food every night, you know?
它更像是一家餐馆，你每天晚上都得不停地做饭，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And you don't have to be haunted by the bad night's performance or even get to celebrate that much the good night's for.
你不用为表现糟糕的夜晚而耿耿于怀，甚至也没时间为表现出色的夜晚庆祝太久。
It's just it, it evanesc is that the word it just goes away.
它就是，它会消逝，是这个词吗？它就是消失了。
Right.
对吧。
And with filmed entertainment, uh, I, I found it took me years to, um, become less self conscious and to not think about the kind of like museum quality of it that it would, it would last forever.
而在影视表演方面，呃，我发现我花了多年时间，嗯，才变得不那么自我意识过剩，不再去想那种博物馆品质般的东西——它是会永远保留下去的。
And I always, always, always wanted another take if one was available because I just wanted another whack at the thing.
而且我总是、总是、总是想要再拍一条，如果有机会的话，因为我只是想再试一次。
But, um, it wasn't until I directed my own movies.
但是，嗯，直到我自己导演了电影。
And I was in both the movies I directed where I had to edit myself.
而且我拍的两部电影我都参演了，我还得自己剪辑。
And I learned so much.
我学到了太多。
I learned.
我学到了。
It was weird.
这感觉很奇妙。
It's something happened to me where I was like, I know what I look like now.
我身上发生了一些变化，当时我就想：我现在知道自己长什么样了。
You know when you're a kid and you hear your voice on tape for the first time and you're like, horrified, you're like, that can't be what I sound like, right?
你知道当你还是个孩子的时候，第一次在磁带里听到自己的声音，你会觉得毛骨悚然，你会想：我的声音听起来绝不可能是这样的，对吧？
You go through that a little bit when you see yourself on camera, like Craig and Carter as the fireman or the EMT guys, but you still haunts me.
当你第一次在镜头里看到自己时，也会经历这种感觉，就像Craig和Carter演的消防员或者急救人员那样，但这仍然让我挥之不去。
There was this feeling once I edited myself, I was like, I didn't think I looked particularly good or bad.
自我剪辑过一次后，我有一种感觉，我觉得自己看起来并没有特别好或特别坏。
I just knew what I looked like and I had a kind of ruthless acceptance of it.
我只是知道了自己长什么样，并且对它有一种无情的接受。
And since I've done that, I have a much easier time watching myself on screen.
自从我做了这件事之后，我在银幕上看着自己时就轻松多了。
It still pops up where you're like, I don't know or I wish they would have chosen a different take or something.
有时候还是会冒出一些想法，比如：我不知道啊，或者我希望他们当时选的是另一条素材之类的。
And it's hard.
这真的很难。
It's hard.
太难了。
I think that people don't understand how much self-consciousness is induced by acting on screen.
我觉得人们并不理解，在镜头前表演会带来多么严重的自我意识过剩。
And when I see people, you know, like Lizzy Olson, who was in my first, in my second movie, Liberal Arts, like, she was just, she's just two of the men are born.
当我看到那些人，你知道的，比如Lizzy Olson，她演了我的第一部、我的第二部电影《艺术学院》，她简直天生就是吃这碗饭的。
I think Kobe was like this too, like they're just comfortable being photographed and, you know, fussed over in a way that I, coming from the theater and I don't know, just my general kind of level of self-consciousness back in those days, I had a harder time relaxing.
我觉得Kobe也是这样，他们就是能泰然自若地被拍照，然后被人众星捧月般地伺候着。而我，出身于戏剧界，而且不知道为什么，加上我当年那种普遍的自我意识过剩，我很难彻底放松下来。
I feel like I know how to act in front of the camera in a totally different way than I did 20 years ago.
我觉得我现在在镜头前表演的方式，和20年前完全不同了，我知道该怎么演了。
All right.
好吧。
We have two questions representing many who asked the same.
我们有两个问题，代表了许多人的共同提问。
Let's do it.
我们开始吧。
PJ Chandra 612 says, what was the inspiration behind a blue French horn?
PJ Chandra 612问：蓝色法国号背后的灵感是什么？
I mean, I think that came from, I remember us wanting to, by the way, it's right over Josh's shoulder right there.
我的意思是，我觉得这来自于，我记得我们当时想让——顺便说一句，它就在Josh的肩膀后面。
It's the next question on camera here and our little, if anyone's YouTubeing us, it's fantastic.
这是这里的下一个镜头问题，在我们的画面里，如果有人在YouTube上看我们的话，这太棒了。
It makes me very happy.
这让我非常高兴。
Josh, there's a lovely fire.
Josh，那里有一场可爱的炉火。
I can't tell if you have the fire today.
我分不清你今天有没有生火。
You do?
你生了？
It's a lovely fire.
这火真好看。
It's a winter.
冬天嘛。
There's the blue punch on it.
蓝色法国号就在那儿。
It's very appealing.
非常吸引人。
It came from the idea that Carter and I were, we knew we wanted Ted to have to bring something in this sort of very elemental storytelling way, like you've got to, he's got to bring the heroine, a gift to gain entry into her layer.
这个想法源于，我和Carter当时知道，我们想让Ted带点东西来，采用那种非常原始的故事讲述方式，就像你必须——他必须带给女主角一件礼物，才能进入她的闺房。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
There was just this sort of almost like Greek mythological, like he must, he must get a gift and that will gain him access into her world.
这就有点像希腊神话，好像他必须、必须得到一件礼物，从而获得进入她世界的通行证。
A boon, yeah, it really was.
一份恩赐，对，确实如此。
It feels very like Joseph Campbell, mythology, kind of like just like, let's, let's boil it down to the hero needs to do this to sort of earn his way.
感觉非常像约瑟夫·坎贝尔的 mitologia（神话学），有点像——让我们把它精简为英雄需要做这件事来赢得他的准入资格。
And then it was like, let's think of something memorable like a hang on a wall.
然后就变成了：让我们想一个令人难忘的东西，比如挂在墙上的东西。
And I was like, we got to that.
我就想：我们最终选定了这个。
You also get the feeling Ted was not into thieving that much.
你也会有一种感觉，Ted其实并不是那么喜欢偷东西的人。
Like he doesn't seem like he was a guy who stole a lot of things off a wall from restaurants.
你看他根本不像是那种会从餐馆墙上偷东西的人。
I was, is this a, I had these moments a lot, but I'm like, we should have talked about that.
我当时在想，这算是一个——我经常会有这种时刻，心想：我们当时应该讨论一下这个。
Like Ted, do you ever stolen anything before?
比如Ted，你以前偷过东西吗？
That could have been a whole episode.
这本来可以拍成整整一集。
Like, the whole gang stole something.
比如，死党们偷了东西。
Damn it.
见鬼。
But yeah, that, that would have been a new thing for Ted.
但话又说回来，对Ted来说，这会是一次全新体验。
I believe in my heart.
我内心深信。
That was, that was his first theft, I think.
那绝对是，那绝对是他的第一次偷窃，我是这么认为的。
And he, the idea that he had to run in and do, And sort of like going back to Josh's earlier comment about sort of humiliating yourself in order to sort of move forward in the game, he had to run and jump on to a couple's dinner table, put his knee in like the entrees and grab this thing off the wall, or this couple is sort of a humiliating and sane thing to do, but it got him to the next level of the the rom-com video game to go meet the boss.
而且他必须冲进去完成这一幕，这就有点回到Josh刚才提到的为了在游戏中继续前进而不惜自我羞辱——他不得不冲过去跳上一对情侣的餐盘桌，把膝盖踩进主菜里，然后把墙上的这个东西抓下来，或者对这对情侣做这种极具羞辱性且疯狂的事情。但这让他进入了浪漫喜剧电子大作的下一关，去见大Boss。
I do remember shooting that and enjoying it.
我确实记得拍摄那一幕时非常享受。
It was so quick.
节奏太快了。
It was fun.
很有趣。
doing your own stunt.
自己完成特技动作。
Like it was a little like there was some athleticism to it, you know, it was really fun.
感觉有点像，里面包含了一些运动天赋，你知道的，真的很有趣。
I was surprised rewatching it.
重看的时候我甚至很惊讶。
I was like, oh, he really had to climb up on a table.
我心想：哦，他真的得爬到桌子上去啊。
There was really me climbing up on that table.
那真的是我爬上了那张桌子。
I was actually all his own stunts there.
他当时真的是自己完成所有的特技动作。
Well, Yvonne Vasku, sorry, Yvonne does ask, did any of you keep the blue French horn?
好吧，Yvonne Vasku——抱歉，Yvonne确实问了：你们当中有人留下了那支蓝色法国号吗？
And remember, this is audio, this is an audio format, Josh, so please talk to us through this over my my right shoulder.
记住，这是音频，这是一个音频节目，Josh，所以请对着我的右肩膀这边跟我们聊聊这个。
We were just kind of asked by the props department and by Carter and Craig like if you could take one thing and I asked for the Blue French horn and I don't, I didn't, I mean, it was so associated with Ted, I don't think there was a lot of competition for, for, you know, I don't think Carter on bartender is like, give me that.
道具部门以及Carter和Craig曾问过我们，如果你能带走一样东西，你会选什么？我当时就要了蓝色法国号，而且我没——我的意思是，它跟Ted的联系太紧密了，我觉得大家不会为了它产生太多竞争，你知道的，我绝不觉得Carter或酒保会说：“把那个给我。”
Yeah.
对。
So yeah, so I asked for the horn and it's traveled with me.
所以，是的，我要了这支号，它一直跟着我。
I'm now in, I now live in Albuquerque, New Mexico.
我现在住在——我现在住在新墨西哥州的阿尔伯克基。
Yeah.
是的。
But it's been with me for a number of years.
但它已经跟我好多年了。
Yeah.
是的。
It makes me so happy every time we do this podcast to see it over Josh's right shoulder.
每次我们做这个播客，看到它出现在Josh的右肩膀后面，我都觉得特别高兴。
It makes me every time I sort of forget that it's there and then it's there and it's like it's delightful.
每次我都差点忘了它在那里，然后一抬头看到它，就觉得太棒了。
So by the way, you just mentioned the bartender.
顺便说一句，你刚才提到了酒保。
Do you guys know Joe, right?
你们认识Joe，对吧？
Do you guys know his story of how he wound up on nine seasons of the show.
你们知道他是怎么在这个拍了九季的节目里演到最后的吗？
Do you know how it started?
你们知道这一切是怎么开始的吗？
Well, I mean, I do because I was there.
嗯，我的意思是，我知道，因为我当时就在现场。
Do you mean we're there?
你是说我们都在场？
Can he tell the story?
能让他自己讲这个故事吗？
He was, he was going to be a cop that appeared, that appeared in a whole sequence that got axled on the show.
他本来，他本来要演一个警察，出现在节目中整段被砍掉的戏份里。
I think we cut it.
我想我们把它剪掉了。
I'm not sure we even, I think we didn't even, did we shoot it?
我不确定我们是不是——我想我们甚至连——我们当时拍了吗？
God, we didn't shoot it.
天哪，我们根本没拍。
He showed up.
他出现了。
We can't.
我们不能。
He showed up.
他出现了。
He, he, right.
他，对。
I think production forgot to call him and tell him it's cut.
我觉得制片组忘打电话通知他戏份被剪了。
Yes.
对。
That was right.
没错。
And he got in his costume.
然后他还穿上了戏服。
Someone put a costume on him of a cop.
有人给他换上了一身警察的戏服。
He showed up and that's an, that's a question that will haunt me.
他赶到了现场，这，这是一个一直困扰我的问题。
Did Wardrobe know it was cut but was like, let's put him in the cop out there.
服装组当时知道戏被剪了吗，还是说“算了，就让他穿着警察的戏服去吧”？
We don't want to be the one to tell him.
我们可不想当那个去通知他的人。
That's now that I don't know that question.
现在回想起来，我还真不知道答案。
So wait, he shows up to set in a cop outfit and you say, sorry, this has been cut.
等等，他穿着警察的服装来到片场，然后你们说，抱歉，这段被剪了。
No, you can get behind the bar and be the bartender.
不，你可以去吧台后面演酒保。
That was that's it.
当时就是这样的。
Yeah, that was it.
对，就是这样。
We felt it because we were still casting the bartender role and we liked him and we had to cast him and then cut this thing at the last minute about a cop.
我们当时有这种感觉，因为我们还在物色酒保的角色，我们很喜欢他，必须得用他，结果最后一分钟把那个警察的戏份给剪了。
It was like a cop that was going to come on there more than they were all sitting out on the taxi cab outside of Robin's apartment.
原本那个警察会出场更多次，当时他们全都坐在罗宾公寓外面的出租车上。
There was a whole little bit with a cop and I don't even ask me if I've ever been on what it is because I'm kind of blanking on what it really was.
本来有一整段关于警察的小插曲，别问我到底是什么内容，因为我对当时的具体情节有点记不清了。
We cut it and we felt so bad that the message never got to him somehow and that we said, you were great.
我们把那段剪了，心里特别过意不去，不知怎么地这消息一直没传达到他那里，于是我们对他说，你演得太棒了。
Let's make you Carl the bartender and then he appeared for nine years on the show.
让我们让你演酒保卡尔吧，结果他在剧里一演就是九年。
Unbelievable.
难以置信。
Shout out to Joe.
向乔致敬。
Joe was awesome.
乔太棒了。
He was always so much fun to have on set.
片场有他在总是充满欢乐。
He was so chill.
他总是那么随和。
Yeah.
对。
in the pilot, he has that, you have that moment.
在试播集里，他有那个，你有那个镜头。
He glairs at me because he has mean as his girlfriend.
他狠狠地瞪了我一眼，因为他把我看作情敌。
I forgot that moment too.
我也把那个镜头给忘了。
I forgot that.
我都忘了。
我把那事给忘了。
I forgot that she was Carl's girlfriend for a second.
我刚才差一点忘了她曾是卡尔的女友。
I was like one of those little, I mostly had that verbatim that pilot in my brain, but it's like, right, Carl, he, she's dating Carl and he has a good, intimidating look at Ted.
我当时就像，试播集的台词我脑子里基本都能倒背如流，但我就在想，对啊，卡尔，她，她跟卡尔约会，而且他对泰德投去了非常有威慑力的一瞥。
That's great.
太棒了。
Carl.
卡尔。
It's the most noticing there.
那是卡尔最受关注的一次了。
Carl ever got.
卡尔从那以后再也没这么受关注过。
Yeah.
对。
Great.
太棒了。
He was good.
他演得很好。
He had a presence.
他很有存在感。
He was great.
他太棒了。
Go, Joe.
加油，乔。
And I'm sorry about the cop thing, Joe, but I guess it worked out way.
抱歉啊乔，关于那个警察的角色，不过我想结果也算歪打正着吧。
We have so many questions and so little time.
我们有那么多问题，而时间却这么少。
Craig, you and I have bonded over for all of our many, many decades together, but it is Douglas asked what books, TV shows or stories in general help guide how to tell the first episode.
克雷格，我们俩这么多年来建立了深厚的友情，但道格拉斯问了一个问题：有哪些书、电视剧或故事大纲指导了你们如何构思第一集？
I guess, bigger question, what are your biggest writing, comedy influences?
我想，换作更大的问题，你们最大的编剧和喜剧灵感来源是什么？
I mean, Carter would have a certain set of answers that would be very important to this too.
我是说，卡特对这个问题肯定有一套非常重要的见解。
I won't attempt to speak for him, but so many of our answers were overlaps.
我不打算替他回答，但我们的很多答案是不谋而合的。
This is one.
这就是其中之一。
Cheers.
《干杯》。
I think we wanted to do a show that had a bar in it.
我想我们当时就想拍一部里面有酒吧的剧。
You wanted to hang out with these people at the bar, and we wanted the bar to be super inviting and warm and amazing, and we just took that from cheers.
你希望和这些人一起在酒吧闲逛，我们希望这个酒吧超级温馨、热情、迷人，这一点我们完全是借鉴了《干杯》。
But we also love Quentin Tarantino, and we love slicing and dicing narratives and storytelling and finding these nonlinear crazy ways to tell stories.
但我们也喜欢昆汀·塔伦蒂诺，我们喜欢把叙事和故事拆解重组，用这些非线性、疯狂的方式来讲述故事。
So it's a Quentin Tarantino plus cheers equals how much your mother with someone Harry Metzeli thrown in.
所以，昆汀·塔伦蒂诺加上《干杯》就等于《老爸老妈的浪漫史》，或许还得加上一点哈里·梅齐利。
I think you guys told me on the pilot that you had pitched Ted as Lloyd Dobbler from say anything meets George Bailey from its wonderful life.
我觉得你们俩在拍试播集的时候对我说过，你们把泰德定位为《情到深处》里的劳埃德·多布勒结合《生活多美好》里的乔治·贝利。
Were those the two comps that you gave?
这就是你们给出的两个参考对象吗？
Absolutely.
绝对是的。
Big time.
千真万确。
And with a special emphasis on George Bailey, I think.
而且特别强调了乔治·贝利，我觉得。
Because think about the planning aspect, I'm going to plan my future.
因为想想规划这方面，我要规划我的未来。
This is what the future is going to be.
未来的生活将会是这样的。
I've got it all mapped out.
我都已经规划好了。
I mean, in some ways beef should, it's an actionable rip-off.
从某种程度上说，老实说，这简直是个彻头彻尾的抄袭。
We really, we really took a lot from it.
我们真的，真的从里面借鉴了很多。
Some Georgia Valley main character of its wonderful life for you, kids playing along in the home game.
对于那些在家里跟着猜的游戏迷朋友们，《生活多美好》的主角乔治·贝利。
He's this big dreamer who thinks he's going to plan everything out and life proves otherwise and life also proves that there's a richness to be found when it doesn't all go according to plan.
他是一个胸怀大志的梦想家，以为自己能把一切都规划好，但生活却证明并非如此，生活同时也证明，当一切没有按计划进行时，反而能发现其中的丰富多彩。
I'd say that was a big spiritual forebearer of Ted, but Lloyd Dobler, big time.
可以说这是泰德在精神上的重要先驱，不过劳埃德·多布勒也是绝对的。
I mean, so much so with Lloyd Dobler that when you walked in the door and like had a little Qzaki inequality to you, Josh, it's red first.
我是说，对劳埃德·多布勒的借鉴非常多，以至于你一走进门，身上就带着一种约翰·库萨克式的特质，乔什，这是初版剧本。
So you're not to say like you seemed like John Geary your own man, but it definitely helped like there was kind of like a wit and an intelligence and your eyes had felt like a young John Qzaki.
所以并不是说——你看起来就像约翰·库萨克本人，但这种感觉确实很有帮助，有一种机智和聪明，你的眼神感觉就像年轻时的约翰·库萨克。
Oh no.
哦，不。
At that time, my life is someone called me.
我生活中的那个时期，有人这么叫过我。
That's a compliment.
这是个赞美。
And I would, I would take it as a big compliment.
我会把它当作极大的赞美来接受。
You don't miss it.
你不会错过的。
Okay.
好的。
Yeah.
对。
Mentos is a big compliment.
曼妥思是个极大的赞美。
My last question on paper here is from Chris.ram asks, will you be filming this podcast?
我这里纸条上的最后一个问题来自Chris.ram，他问，你们会把这个播客拍成视频吗？
So here we are.
所以我们就这么做了。
They're very excited.
他们非常兴奋。
If you are listening to this right now, just know that this is also on YouTube.
如果你现在正在听这个节目，请知道这也是在YouTube上同步播出的。
You can check it out.
你可以去看看。
There's so many questions about this pilot.
关于这个试播集有太多的问题了。
There's 300 more here on Instagram and everywhere.
在Instagram和其他地方，这里还有三多百个问题。
Is there anything left?
还有什么没说的吗？
What else should we talk about about the pilot?
关于试播集我们还应该聊点什么？
Because we're moving on to episode two.
因为我们要进入第二集了。
I would just say that one thing that struck me watching the pilot was the sense memory of the challenge of having to have Robin meet the rest of the gang.
我只想说，看试播集时触动我的一点是，那种必须让罗宾与其他人相遇的挑战所带来的直观记忆。
Robin, Kobe Smolder's, only has scenes with Josh in the pilot.
罗宾（寇碧·史莫德斯饰）在试播集中只有和乔什的对手戏。
never interacts with anybody else.
她从来没有跟其他人互动过。
And I remember that feeling at the end of the pilot, like, we better have a good episode, too, that shows how she kind of works her way into this group and be friends with this group because that's a whole other sale we have to make of, like, she's the fifth banana.
我记得在试播集结尾时那种感觉：我们最好在第二集拍个好点的剧情，展现她是如何融入这个群体并和大家成为朋友的，因为这是我们要推销的另一个大点：她算老几。
She's, you know, she's the, she's the fifth part of this five-part puzzle.
她，你知道的，她，她是这个五人拼图中的第五块。
And we had to sort of integrate her and show how everybody else kind of fell in love with her, too.
我们得把她融合进来，并展示其他人是如何也开始喜欢上她的。
And I, I had that feeling in my body.
我当时身体里真切地感受到了那种压力。
It's sort of re-experienced that, like, we got to somehow thread the needle on out.
重新体验到了那种感觉，就像我们必须在这一点上找到平衡。
We got to make the sale.
我们得把这个设定卖给观众。
Like, I remember feeling that way When we had to write episode two and three and that we're sort of like showing her becoming part of that group and yeah It was just fun.
就像我记得当我们不得不写第二集和第三集时那种感觉，我们要展现她如何成为那个群体的一部分，是的，这真的很有趣。
Remember that challenge and we'll rewatch and talk about if we if we did it I think we did I think we pulled it off.
记住那个挑战，我们接下来会重温并讨论我们是否做到了，我觉得我们做到了，我觉得我们成功了。
I have two things one is if you watch the pilot of how I met your mother the DNA for the entire show is in the pilot Yeah, like absolutely the entire kind of structure and essence and and surprise switcheroo kind of thing that they did so well, it's all, it's in there.
我有两件事，第一件是如果你看了《老爸老妈浪漫史》的试播集，整部剧的DNA在试播集里就已经具备了。是的，整部剧的结构、精髓以及那种大反转的把戏，他们玩得那么溜的东西，全都在里面了。
It's like the raggoo sauce or whatever.
就像那个拉古酱或者别的什么一样。
It's like it's in there.
就像它就在那里面。
What people understand that, you can cut that if they don't.
大家能懂就行，如果不懂的话可以剪掉。
The other thing I wanted to say, this is just a funny thing that my wife said this morning.
我另外想说的一件事，这只是我太太今天早上说的一个趣事。
She was like, she knew someone who had, who lived on the upper west side and he had a dog named Teddy and everyone called him the dog Teddy West side.
她说她认识一个人，住在上西区，他有一只狗叫泰迪，大家都叫这只狗“上西区泰迪”。
And I love, as one of Ted's, he had so many nicknames, Teddy West sides a great nickname, I thought, but it was also self-proclaimed, right?
我觉得，作为泰迪的众多外号之一，“上西区泰迪”真是一个很棒的外号，但这也是他自封的对吧？
He called himself Teddy West side.
他自称是“上西区泰迪”。
Yeah, I think he was trying to get everyone else on board.
对，我觉得他当时是想让大家都这么叫。
They weren't on board.
但大家并不买账。
Yeah, but she said, so where'd they live?
对，但她就说，那他们住哪儿？
And I said, they lives on the upper west side, right?
我说，他们住在上西区啊，对吧？
Yeah.
对。
And she said, but Robin lives in Brooklyn.
然后她说，但罗宾住在布鲁克林啊。
And I said, yeah, she said, because Robin's cool, because we, like, Jordan, she grew up in Manhattan, but she lives in Brooklyn and she just can't stand going into Manhattan.
我说，对啊，她说，因为罗宾很酷，因为我们……就像乔丹一样，她在曼哈顿长大，但她住在布鲁克林，而且她就是受不了去曼哈顿。
She loves Brooklyn.
她超爱布鲁克林。
But she said, how was she hanging out on this bar on the upper west side so much if she lived in Brooklyn?
但她说，如果她住在布鲁克林，怎么会经常在上西区的这家酒吧鬼混呢？
Yeah.
对啊。
She was terrible.
这太离谱了。
Here's what I, here's what I rationalized.
我是这么……我是这么合理解释的。
I think her TV station is close by.
我觉得她的电视台就在附近。
Yeah.
对。
Let's say that TV is in mid, TV stations in Midtown somewhere.
比方说电视台在 中城 的某个地方。
So she's like, why not?
所以她就会想，为什么不呢？
Or even in like the West 60s, like where the West 60s, like that sort of like CBS building, like West 50s, 60s, that whole thing.
甚至就在西60年代那边，就像西60年代那样，比如哥斯比大楼那种地方，西50年代、60年代，大概就是那一带。
So then she just pops up a couple of like 10 or 15 blocks and hangs out with her friend.
所以她只要往上走个十街区或十五街区，就能跟朋友一起玩了。
But also, she's out so late and she has to get up at like 3.30 in the morning to do the early.
不过话说回来，她常常玩到那么晚，然后还得在凌晨3点半左右起床去播早间新闻。
Just a day, like an hour and a half.
路上只要花个一个半小时吧。
These are the kind of threads we'll be pulling, that'll be.
这就是我们接下来要探讨的那些细枝末节……
Yeah, at some point she moves, but it's true.
对，她后来搬家了，不过确实。
For a while she had a real shit commute.
有一段时间她的通勤简直烂透了。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
Olsen's off again.
奥尔森又开播了。
New York City.
纽约市。
how we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我、亚历克·莱夫制作，我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是“蓝色之点”录音室的亚历克斯·里夫斯。
Artwork by John Marrow.
封面插图由约翰·马罗绘制。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或你常用的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这真的对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner.
我们的主题曲是《NYC》，由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作。
special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliott Connards.
特别感谢罗拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳兹。
Visit howwemajormother.com to sign up for our substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
访问 howwemajormother.com 注册我们的 Substack 邮件列表，并获取我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
你也可以点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你们的故事和问题是本节节目不可或缺的重要部分。
Subscribe to Josh Riders' newsletters on substack.
欢迎在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳的时事通讯。
Read Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasRider.com.
在 CraigThomasRider.com 阅读克雷格·托马斯出版的散文作品。
And you can subscribe to my Dead Father Society, also on Substack.
你也可以订阅我的《已故父亲协会》，同样在 Substack 上。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
想了解本节目如何通过持续筹款活动为先天性心脏病研究做出贡献，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”标签页。
This episode was made possible by the support of backyard ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
本期节目得到了“后院风险投资”的大力支持，营销由 Tink 媒体提供。
People will, in fact, dance.
人们其实是会跳舞的。
The real question, it just hit me Am I in love with you or just New York's?
真正的问题是，我突然意识到——我是爱上了你，还是仅仅爱上了纽约？